Hedberg could just go on for days he had
so much [ __ ] material man that guy
wrote constantly he was always writing
till the end in the end you know the
drugs got to him obviously they killed
him but he was his that's a that's a
non-sequitur style that's the hardest
style of comedy you say one thing and
then you say something totally unrelated
the next joke and the next jokes totally
unrelated
no no sequencing or no man and you you
know it's all segways I'm sorry no see
yeah that's abut sequency too it's like
they don't don't fit in together in any
way way shape or form
they're just total non sequiturs just
here's a funny thing I thought of here's
another funny thing I thought of you
know and it's but his style was so
unique
just the way he delivered things were so
unique he was funny just talking about
nothing like talking about anything one
of my favorite jokes are his he goes uh
he goes somebody asked me if I want a
frozen banana I said no but I want a
regular banana later so yes that's just
silly joke but it's such a great job
that's a STONER joke oh man
all day he's got like one of the best
his albums are that some of the best
donor material of all time maybe the
best